as coronavirus has spread across the
country it's been up to each state to
figure out how to combat it and what
that means for the businesses that have
been forced to close the restaurant
industry is now facing 240 billion
dollars in annual losses because the
restaurants have largely shuttered their
dining rooms and are trying to make up
the difference through takeout and
delivery reopening is now starting
across the country and as the rollout
continues it's creating unique
challenges for restaurants with
locations and multiple states that now
have to navigate pandemic operations
under conflicting guidelines rhombus
guys pizza is located in Grand Forks a
city split by the Red River that extends
into both North Dakota and Minnesota
it's two locations in North Dakota can
now serve customers at 50% capacity but
the third location in Minnesota has been
surviving on take-out sales and won't
reopen until June 1st so I was driving
from a Grand Forks location here to our
Fargo location just before Saint
Patrick's Day and on the radio the
President of the United States broke in
and he didn't say a hard-and-fast you
have to stay home at that point but at
that point he said that he recommended
that people do not go out to eat at
restaurants and it was exactly at that
moment I knew that we were in for
trouble we're kind of in a unique
position that's that we have both pizza
restaurants in North Dakota as well as
in Minnesota and it's a seasonal
location and so it was not open up when
the initial news came out and the
pandemic team down and so we were really
focused on North Dakota these are our
full time restaurants are much larger
restaurants since then we've now opened
up in Minnesota at our seasonal location
so I kind of had to start learning what
was going on over there Minnesota has
put down similar guidelines and similar
restrictions to what North Dakota did
they came down with the restrictions
before North Dakota in terms of closing
down
drones and bars and moly lowing dining
in carry out and they've held on to that
longer than North Dakota and so still
currently in Minnesota it is only
takeout and delivery they also were much
slower to allow and to adopt the the
order of allowing restaurants to provide
beer wine and liquor with their carry
out and delivery in fact still to the
state and don't allow it for for
delivery and they only allow beer and
wine for takeoff the pandemic has also
put the local government under pressure
to both address the needs of small
business and contain the spread of the
virus in the community Grand Forks and
East Grand Forks have been communicating
about how do we keep each other safe and
Grand Forks people do go across the
river to do takeout and I think we're
working hard to keep each other
nama CLE healthy so it's constant
communication we respect each other's
rules and then we want to keep each
other safe well the difficulty
coordinating our guidelines between
North Dakota so it's like they're
staying placed but they have jobs over
here so then they get to come across the
border and then work here but the
following are the CDC guidelines to keep
you safe and then they go on pateros
they shelter in place for another two
weeks that but here we're doing the grab
for something not to go to smartly start
to get things back from lunch a normal
we were trying to figure out how we're
gonna stay alive as a business and what
was that going to look like and we knew
that we needed to pivot our business
model and do whatever we could because
we had made the decision that we were
going to stay open we were gonna do what
we could to try to generate revenue I
know other restaurants in town and
across the state just shut down they
didn't even attempt to do carry out or
delivery well the pizza model lends
itself fairly nicely do that model we
already
is you know a significant amount of
carry out and of delivery throw all this
no difference guidelines have been
passed down to restaurants whether it's
okay shut down for dine in and only do
carry out and delivery okay here's PPP
money and lay everybody off now bring
everybody back ok now you're allowed to
open up but you're allowed to open up
within these guidelines and so we feel
like we're constantly pivoting and
changing business models and trying to
figure out how to successfully move
forward both for the business and the
financial side but also the safety side
of the staff and our guests where the
difficulty comes in is more on the
people side of things
and then the financial side of things
and so it's stately saying okay you guys
can open up but you have to open up
within this realm and then we go and we
talk to our staff and the staff says
whoa this is really too quick and and us
as business owners say yeah it does feel
like it's too quick and how do we do
this safely and how do we pivot again
and how do we make both our our
employees feel comfortable as well as
yes coming in the difficult thing is the
is the mental side of it are we
comfortable going up to a table and
interacting with people now again are we
comfortable with people walking through
the front door I think that our local
businesses are handling us to us that's
been put on them by the virus by
reacting cautiously because we open
things and the governor opened things up
again some people would think about
what's going to be business as normal
but some restaurants are reluctant to
open because if your restaurant gets
tagged is a quote of 19 focus and your
business is going to suffer from that so
they were very cautious and real opening
and they make their employees wear
personal protective equipment and
they're encouraging their customers to
wear personal protective equipment as
well as the physical distances so I
think our businesses are anxious to get
back to normal but they're being very
cautious because as I said before this
is highly contagious but actually fatal
so we have deep roots here and I think
it's a lot of caring back and forth and
I think that we want our neighbors to
succeed and they want us to succeed so I
think that's why we work together we
have a common goal it says we're a
community with a river running through
it
not to separate states but those guys
like sometimes by the governor's do
cause them you know like their shelter
in a place we're stay at home which is
very different so I think we work it out
and we support each other and we shop
over there to keep their businesses
healthy and they shop and we're here to
keep our community healthy from my
limited experience over the last week of
seeing how this smart restart happens is
I think there is going to be lingering
effects of this and not small lingering
effects but large lingering effects of
this even haven't just been open for a
week I think that our staff is feeling a
little more comfortable you know in the
way of dealing with people as long as
we're doing it in a smart manner you
know keeping people separated and I
think that you know people coming in or
seeing that it can be done in a safe way
but I don't see people flocking back to
busy packed restaurants and or rooftops
any time soon so I think it's gonna take
some time and we're you fully believe
that the year 2020 is more or less shot
for us in terms of business we happen to
be you know relatively strong financial
companies so we're lucky we feel like we
can come out of this on the other side I
want the community and the people to
realize hey these are the local
businesses these are the ones that are
important to our community these are the
identity of our community they worked
really hard during this whole pandemic
to keep their staff so you can keep the
guest safe and we need to support them
coming out the other side and that's
what I want to see at the end of all of
this
you
[Music]